well the core theme of transient
advantage as I like to refer to it is a
departure from the traditional view in
strategy that what you wanted to create
was what was called a sustainable
competitive advantage and the classical
idea was that you found an attractive
position within an industry through up
entry barriers like crazy and then you
defended that position against
competition and as I've worked with
companies as I've worked around the
world what became pretty clear was that
traditional view of strategy was not
only not really well reflected in what
was going on but that it was actually
dangerous that it causes companies to do
a lot of stupid things like focus
excessively on your competition rather
than really thinking about your customer
focus excessively on your industry
rather than thinking really about the
arenas in which you're competing and
most dangerous of all focus on stability
when what you need to really be thinking
about is change and dynamism so the book
the end of competitive advantage was
really meant to begin a conversation
about what strategy looks like today for
more and more of our companies well I
think the idea of sustainable
competitive advantage really got
entrenched in the strategy lexicon in
the 1960s and 70s in the u.s. primarily
and if you think about those times if
you go back in time to when those
concepts were first developed you know
India was shut
China was shut most of Eastern Europe
was behind the Iron Curtain we didn't
have competition in markets from the
USSR so if you think about it American
companies had a pretty big period of
stability in which they got to compete
and so the essence of competition back
then was really about the classics right
scale scope comparative advantage
optimization running efficiently because
that's what got you the real edge
because you didn't have global
competition you didn't have the internet
you didn't have digitization you didn't
have some kid in a garage able to invent
something that four weeks later is worth
a billion dollars I mean you just didn't
have those phenomena and so I think what
we have clung to in strategy is this
notion of sustainable advantage for a
lot of reasons it was very traditional
it worked very well and the other big
secret I think behind this notion of
sustainable advantage is there are a lot
of analytical tools
along with it so in a relative position
in an industry relative market share is
reflected in the well-known Boston
Consulting Group matrix there's a lot of
analytical tools and for an MBA type
audience analytical tools have a real
attractiveness to them so instead here I
am saying well analysis of the past
doesn't really help you and you can't
really do industry comparisons and come
up with very much this useful in fact
you can't analyze your way to a
competitive advantage at all and that
seems a little bit destabilizing so I
think people like to cling to what's
familiar they like to cling to the tools
and concepts that they know best and
that's why I think it's been such
adorable idea what's interesting also is
the reaction that I've gotten to the
book so the reaction to the book kind of
falls in three buckets the so the first
bucket is people who go oh no it doesn't
apply to me doesn't apply to me at all
not part of my industry this is just
isn't my reality the second bucket is
people who panic you know they just try
to change everything all at once they go
sprouting off in all directions and
usually that doesn't go very well and
the third bucket is people who go okay
well if that's the way the world is
working today kind of a sigh of relief
yes this maps onto my reality much
better than these other concepts now I
can think about that and start to get on
with it and so I think that third
category are going to do a lot better in
these transient advantage assist
scenarios than the first two so I'm
often asked ok what's really different
about strategy today then the way that
we've traditionally thought of it and
I've developed what I call a new
playbook for strategy which consists of
six fundamental building blocks you can
think of the first one is to
continuously reconfigure what you're
doing rather than depending on a huge
seismic change that involves massive
restructuring and downsizing the second
is getting much better at disengagement
being able to stop activities that are
no longer relevant or stop ventures that
you started that just aren't panning out
the way that you'd hoped
the third is getting a firm handle on
your resource allocation process because
what often happens in companies is
powerful people running core businesses
get to call the shots with regard to
where the resources get spent and if you
want to know how that ends up just look
at blackberry or Nokia or any of those
firms where powerful people tried to
defend their advantages far longer than
they should have
the fourth is innovation and I
argue that innovation has to become a
proficiency it can't just be episodic it
can't just be something we do once in a
while this also has pretty profound
implications for leaders I think leaders
need to be increasingly discovery driven
meaning they have to be able to adapt
their mindset as new information comes
in and they have to be very candid and
willing to have frank discussions about
what's really going on
lastly I think all of this has huge
implications for individuals and how we
structure our jobs how we structure our
careers what we do both as employers and
as persons who are working ourselves and
I think the traditional career path for
a whole lot of people is going to be
radically different than anything we've
seen before so if you put all this
together what it amounts to is a set of
practices which are not unheard of but
which I think very few firms today have
really embraced